all right alfonso
alfonso where'd you grow up where are
you from up in chicago illinois on the
west side of roosevelt
and tell me about your childhood you had
mom and dad as a kid you had a mom and
dad when i was a kid mom got killed you
know doing a gang activity they came
looking for me my brother we wasn't
there they shot my mom and all that
oh really you guys were in gangs yeah
what how old were you when this happened
15 15. and they shot your mom and said
yeah instead of me and my brother they
were looking for you guys yeah wow
so then we came out here to california
in the orange county area but where was
your dad my dad been in prison all his
life in juliet
you know i just grew up my mom just
basically raised me
she didn't raise me she raised me from
my kid to 15.
after that we came out to california
the orange county area and who'd you
stay with them uh grandmother
yeah she raised me then from like 15 to
21
from there i was ending out the
institution all my life were you and
gangs in la as well as
chicago yeah i'm feeling the game
is there any connection between the
chicago gangs and the la gangs and
basically mostly all the gds they turn
crips you know what i'm saying and we
just translate from there to here you
know what i'm saying came out here and
stayed on the same type of level yeah
but now i'm old [ __ ] paperwork so
and basically do you know what i'm
saying so how old do you know um i just
turned 52 man september september 18th
and you're still
you still consider yourself in a gang
right yes it is yeah
sounds like you're always still active
still
you
active
yeah
to a certain extent right you know i
mean i don't go way out my way looking
for problems problems they know who i am
i know where they are you know what i'm
saying so
if they don't come in disrespectful
matter i'm not going to respect them but
if they start you know i'm saying coming
with the negative i'm gonna come you
know i'm saying with some positive try
to eliminate the problem how would you
compare
the gang
situation in chicago to the gang
situation it's more deadly out there in
chicago
because they got they got they bylaws
they go by out there and la seems like
they don't have that many bylaws as far
as codes they go on just like the masons
they have their clothes we have our
codes
you know what i'm saying so try to
emphasize did you finish high school i
went to college for one year i played
basketball for long beach state what are
you doing i messed up my legs man
pulling my acl then i said
yeah
you know now my nieces and nephews ain't
playing college ball for fresno and all
that that's right yeah
my niece one of my nieces is a lawyer
now you're in l.a
that's great you know so i just
basically tried it
i just got out 2011.
i haven't been back to prison since how
much prison time have you done
i've been institutionalized all my life
man
yeah yeah you know i'm saying i just got
off two thousand dollars in and out here
not here now
any chance are you going back again
thanks for god no man
i'm saying i got my daughter man that's
mostly my main subject you know what i'm
saying my daughter are you raising your
daughter now i got food because of young
man you do yeah her name's her name's
africa
and i'm saying so by me doing what i do
how old is she 17 17. birthday the same
day as mine
you know so i just basically try to stay
focused
work here and there you know i'm saying
don't try getting too much involved with
little negative stuff
you know
trying to take this that's my most
priority right there my daughter so
looking back at your life you spend a
lot of time in prison a lot you know run
times on the streets yeah basically i
don't like i'm like being like inside
this little section like i'm like being
encountered you know i'm saying enclosed
my grandma yeah my girl wanted me to
stay in the house and do this and do
that i can't stay inside being inside
themselves every day constantly it's a
throw off of me i like to have come
outside and do my freedom man because
tomorrow's not promised
you know i mean so i'm trying to live
man
i'm sure you've lost a lot of friends i
lost a lot of friends i lost a lot of
homies yeah you know i'm saying but most
of the time considering friends like
they say keep your friends close your
enemies closer i don't consider people
my friends did you did you feel like
when you were younger you feel like
there was an option for you other than
joining your gang it was an option but
once my mom
that was gone
that was my family
joining the game yeah after after you're
losing your mom sure that was my family
but you had basketball
yeah that's you know i'm saying
basketball came later on through the
game as it came later yeah i play that's
what i do i play ball man my age only
reason i can't do nothing now
acl man i can't run and do the things i
want to do man so i just walk around you
know i'm saying
just start to stay focused man stay out
the way man so what are you what's your
life all about now what my life's all
about now i work at a little corner
store like where i stay at you know i'm
sitting out for crocker i try it's a
it's a dude that runs the mic um
the mcintyres i don't know if you heard
that value but they run a store little
corner store yeah not a regular store
but a street store you know i'm saying i
work there you know i'm saying we used
to have one down here on a wall but
somebody crashed into it
he just closed out and started one down
here and drugs are part of your life
drugs what is that
one thing indulgence is alcohol man is
that right yeah my body and all that man
i care for my body i care i'm scared of
germs
have you ever played around with drugs
no never weed is not a drug
yeah
math around that it's not my stealth man
if you have you know i'm saying my
health is more important than doing that
that's why i don't mess with none of
these females out here i'm scared of
germs man i'm germaphobic yeah i'm
saying my health is more important than
before then before i came out here the
blood they shot me in the face
i'm saying i'm shot in the face over
what right here man you know what i'm
saying
parked in the wrong area
i'm saying i could have i could have
died by the time i got to the hospital i
wasted about four sheets of blood man
just just for being in their territory i
didn't know i was hit until i lift my
head up
so i've been going through it man you
know what i'm saying because you're a
[ __ ] and you're you're in blood
territory i wear my blue rag everywhere
i go
no matter what age i am i'm going to
represent it man
that's my life you know i'm saying yeah
but you're aware
it is what it is you know
there's no such thing you know i'm
saying okay you're gonna drop out you're
gonna do this you're gonna do that
that's not part of my life man
you know i know you're just you had your
life to live all over again would you
would you have done this the gang yeah
again no
i wouldn't
i'm saying if god give me another
opportunity another lifestyle i'll
change it's not i'll change i'm changing
through the process now you know saying
that's one of my purposes that's coming
out here to try to start a new life man
even though it's on the street but the
lady lady got me this morning she gave
me a number to call people to help me
with housing
to give me a place to stay my priorities
come first so i know what i'm supposed
to do and what i'm not supposed to do
that's great you know what i'm saying as
long as i keep following god's path i'm
going to keep my head above water
regardless what's your what's your
biggest regret my biggest regret is
losing my mama
i said that's all no more not less than
that did you feel responsible for that
yes i did
some i'm gang affiliated if we was there
then it wouldn't went the opposite way
it's got to be a lot to live with i do
it every mother's day man
i'll stay to myself man
i don't deal with nobody i just go
wherever i walk that's where i walked in
man
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
i try to drink man just to eliminate
that pain
what i go through then my sister and
them they they want to come out here and
see me and this and that one my sister
she does she's a full-on christian she
comes out here bring me clothes and
stuff like that you know that's why i
could get by so you're technically
homeless
i'm not i'm not really homeless i just
don't like being
i could go home but i just don't like it
right
you know people trying to tell me do
this do that if i want to change i'm
changing my own is that from spending so
much time in prison yes yeah you can't
tell me to change i'm gonna change i'm
gonna change i'm gonna change them all
you know what i'm saying i'm all
tomorrow's not too promised man that's
what i'm trying to live man since i've
been institution a lot let me enjoy
myself give me a little freedom man
i'm saying i left my ex-wife to get from
inside the house until this day man
she's still mad at me man
you know what i'm saying you always tell
me every time i call my phone you left
me okay
you know what i'm saying i can't beat
you want me to stay in do this dude
that's not my st that's not my get down
man
i'm saying i'm just trying to ease my
way through it man and just see what i'm
saying look at the outcome of this man
you know i got i got
cdl licensed i'm a welder all that man
i learned that trade in prison you know
what i'm saying but we'll see this
[ __ ] man
are your friends now
you have friends i got one friend okay
man upstairs
that's it that's all man other than that
i do me man every time you see me i'll
be solo polo man
you know what i'm saying that's what i
can't tell myself
you know what i'm saying so that's the
best way of going man
you know homie comes down to see me
every once in a while
after that that's it that's all man i do
me man what are you what are you afraid
of at this point in your life
what i'm afraid of this is my daughter
that's the most important thing to me
it is what it is but i want her to be
raised up man i want her to be raised
the right way man yeah and talk the
right thing that goes to college doing
what she got to do man to be a woman you
feel you're making up for the years that
you weren't there for her yeah yeah
she's not making up for the it's the
years that i missed i heard growing up
man you know i mean
being that father figure boy
just right now this is nothing
you know i'm saying every time i get
about a thousand something dollars
out of here for doing this and doing
that i'll send it to her man every other
weekend man it is what it is that's what
i do
i don't do drugs i sell drugs man that's
the difference
you know i'm saying that the drug do you
do the job did spending time in prison
was it helpful
he got me he got my mind right you know
i'm saying got me in the state of mind
you know what i'm saying reading
understanding things in a different
manner
you know i'm saying really all about the
laws is understanding the laws what's
this and what's that and what people
police tend to do and what they cannot
do
you know i'm saying what's my rights and
what's their right
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life the
most important lesson i've learned in my
life it's respect man
you know what i'm saying that's a great
one that's it that's all man you know
i'm saying respect the person the person
don't respect you treat the person when
you want to be treated man don't send
everything and fall back on you man
other than that
life is short man you got to enjoy it
man
as long as i'm able to see my daughter
you know i'm saying growing up that's
all i want man that's all i got left
it's the only woman i got in my life man
i'm saying that's it
all right alfonso thank you so much for
sharing your story sir i wish you the
best of luck with you and your daughter
yes sir man how is it
you